it's in Malcolm's kitchen where this
strike really hits home
how much pain is she in with the
shoulder
crying pain I mean she she sits there
and cries with her you know his wife
Maureen needs treatment for fluid on the
brain but she also needs shoulder
surgery that operation was due to
finally happen this month unfortunately
says we're going to cancel
ah yeah I says why because it's because
of the strike he says the junior doctor
says we've got no theaters and we've got
no staff she spends much of the day in
bed and Malcolm just keeps topping up
the painkillers which are becoming less
and less effective the NHS hospitals in
their part of Lincolnshire acknowledge
this week will be difficult but say
critical services will keep running it
is the timing of this strike that makes
it so disruptive coming in right after
the long Easter bank holiday weekend and
Junior doctors are so often the ones who
hold it all together when services are
stretched
four days without them means senior
colleagues consultants and other NHS
staff stepping in across England
the contingency plans here at West
Middlesex Hospital in West London are
fairly typical it cannot be business as
usual we'll be prioritizing emergency
surgery we'll be prioritizing Cancer
Care care for children intensive care
patients but there will be patients who
will have their care postponed which
will be very frustrating for patients up
and down the country and there will be a
period where we will have to work
exceptionally hard to try and meet that
backlog of patients which we know exists
at even at this point without the strike
like nurses and ambulance workers Junior
doctors want better pay too
they say the service they provide is in
crisis and that they've had 15 years of
below inflation pay increases
the health secretary says their request
for a 35 pay rise is unrealistic
with no breakthrough the Health Service
in England is once again asking for the
Public's help our main message to the
public this evening is use the NHS
sensibly if you've got a
life-threatening emergency ring 999 but
otherwise make good use of your local
pharmacy your local general practitioner
and the 111 online service because our
hospitals will be under significant
amounts of pressure during the course of
the rest of this week until there's a
settlement patience and their carers
will just muddle through in pain often
alone
it's not the care anyone wants to
provide
Tom Parmenter Sky News Lincolnshire